lundi les bons soirs si je vous dis
carrément obèses est formidable c'est le
type qui a réussi à gouverner avec ses
idées la moitié du monde de bresse de
vladivostok à 1 berlin c'est un exploit
sans précédent pour un philosophe
gorbatchev
quand votre chef j'aime pas je veux dire
je trouve que ça tache de vin est
extrêmement l'aide et elle correspond à
la russie démanteler health in health in
basse et deux de poste seront absolument
fantastique
je crois que c'est un bon signe quand on
veut vraiment gouverner la russie
regardez pierre de grands regardez ivan
le terrible
regardez ce staline c'était tous des
idées des pochetrons il faut être votre
kaïser complètement pour gouverner un
pays comme la russie
bush ma bouche est un esclavage et c'est
vraiment le type du du planteur america
qui bat les esclaves jusqu'au sang et
ensuite va lire la bible à ses enfants à
la pâte
je me souviens du jour où je suis arrivé
en irak lé au commencement de la guerre
je suis allé dans la chambre de yasser
arafat que j'ai rencontrés là-bas il y
avait benbella yasser arafat et moi et
nous avons assisté aux premiers
bombardements qui était un
extraordinaire feu d'artifice tu jamais
jamais rires il peuple d'israël sont pas
du tout la même chose parce qu'on israël
il ya quand même 80 % deux juifs
israéliens qui n'ont pas droit à la
parole ici si on
si on laissait vraiment des israéliens
parler dans la profondeur du peuple
israélien
il est certain qu'il aurait la paix
depuis longtemps juifs les arabes ont
ont cohabité pendant des millénaires
aucune raison que ça ne continue pas
différent à mettet rang mitterrand
comment ça veut dire beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup alors mitterrand ben
un aller simple à latche je crois que ça
soit la meilleure chose qui puisse lui
arriver
bon le pen à le pen je suis pas du tout
pour le pen non plus mais il faut
reconnaître que la vie politique
française à deux pôles le pen et
mitterrand mitterrand et le pen sont
deux hommes qui connaissent très bien la
symbolique en politique c'est à dire
jeanne d'arc pour le pen
et puis le petit monticule grotesque et
est minuscule que franchit une fois l'an
du terran sur des sommes tous les deux à
l'ancienne c'est l'ancienne politique
c'est la politique que je préfère
jusqu'à le coller un froid et très très
habile c'est évident on a vu qu'il
gagnait 7 points aujourd'hui
en parlant de l'invasion mais alors
franchement si la politique c'est
descendent toujours plus bas eh ben je
n'aime pas du tout ces politiques là
kouchner quand il a choisi le pouvoir
j'ai choisi le nom pouvoir il a choisi
la puissance j'ai choisi la souveraineté
c'est quelqu'un pour qui je garderai
toujours une grande tendresse
mais je revendique mon droit d'ingérence
mois dans la politique politicienne
lalonde lalonde ou six états via bimetu
voulez-vous ces gens ont voulu le
pouvoir voulu des prébendes et c'est à
moi je suis rien rien rien du tout je
suis simplement un poète les corrections
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus